[Musik]
in Leipzig wird die Stadt dieses Gebäude
von einer privaten Firma für 14,8
Millionen Euro kaufen eine stolze Summe
für einen alten Kasten allerdings hat
die Stadt erst 2014 genau dieses Gebäude
für gerade mal 500.000 Euro an die
gleiche Firma vertickt unglaublich ein
Rückkauf nach nur acht Jahren und die
Stadt zahlt das 30-fache
dessen Steuergelder müssen nichts dafür
tun da wird nicht überlegt da wird
verschwendet ohne Ende das ist eine
Katastrophe finde ich sprachlos da
fehlen einem Worte das ist wirklich so
da fehlen eine Worte
wirtschaftlich unverantwortlich auch für
die Stadt Leipzig kotzial auf dem Geld
sei eigentlich unser Geld sollte man
nicht so leichtfertig ausgehen 2014 wie
Leipzig die ehemalige ingenieursschule
im Stadtteil Dölitz zu Geld machen das
Gebäude hat über 7.000 Quadratmeter das
Grundstück ist knapp drei Fußballfelder
groß die Stadt hat die Immobilie für
schlappe 500.000 Euro verkauft gegen
alle Warnungen schon kurze Zeit später
wird klar der Immobiliendeal war ein
großer Fehler denn die Verwaltung
braucht dringend Unterkünfte für
geflüchtete übergangsweise hat sie das
Gebäude nun für fünf Jahre gemietet für
54.000 Euro pro Monat aber damit nicht
genug jetzt kauft die Stadt das Gebäude
wieder zurück für satte 14,8 million
Euro eine Geschichte aus dem Tollhaus
ich weiß nicht wie weit voraus
Lokalpolitiker in dem Moment denken
indem sie sowas veräußern ob man dann
auch darüber nachdenkt dass man es
vielleicht noch mal brauchen könnte dann
das merken wir jeden Tag ne
und dort muss raus da haben wir zu viel
angeblich von der Stadt Leipzig will
sich vor der Kamera niemand zu dem Fall
äußern schriftlich erklärt man bei dem
Geschäft sei alles mit rechten Dingen
zugegangen der damalige Verkaufspreis
wurde gutachterlich bestätigt und
entsprach den seinerzeit geltenden
Marktkonditionen eine unter
wertveräußerung lag damit ausdrücklich
nicht vor den ganzen astronomischen
Millionen Deal können viele Leipziger
nicht verstehen ich als normaler Bürger
ich weiß gar nicht mehr was denken soll
entweder bin ich blöde oder die einer
von beiden aber der Preis ist natürlich
unfassbar bis der Kauf endgültig über
die Bühne geht erstes übrigens weiter
kräftig Miete Abdrücken ab Mai wird die
erst noch mal erhöht auf 59.000 Euro